The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SHIMON ULLMAN: What I'm
going to talk about today
is very much related to this
general issue of using vision,
but with sort of the final goal
of seeing and understanding,
in a very deep and
complete manner, what's
going on around you.
And let me start with
just one image we've all--
we see images all
the time, and we
know that we can get a lot
of meaning out of them.
But just, you look at
one image, and you get
a lot of information out of it.
You understand what
happened before, that
was some kind of
a flood, and why
these people are hanging out up
there on the wires, and so on.
So all of this, we
get very quickly.
And what we do, usually, in
computational vision in much
of my own work is
to try to understand
computational schemes
that I can take
as an input, an image
like this, and get
all this information out.
But what I want to talk
about in the first part--
I'm going to break the afternoon
into two different talks on two
different topics, but they
are all closely related
to this ultimate
goal which drives me,
which is, as you will see--
I think it will become
apparent as we go along--
this sort of complete and full
understanding, and complicated
concepts, and complicated
notions that we
can derive from an image.
But what I'm going to
discuss in the first part
is sort of how it all starts.
And this combines vision
with another topic
which is very important in
cognition-- part of CBMM
as well.
But it's not just this
particular center,
it's part of
understanding cognition--
is infant learning
and how it all starts.
And certainly for
vision, and for learning,
this is a very interesting
and fascinating problem.
Because here, you
think about babies,
they open up their eyes.
And they see-- they don't--
they cannot understand
the images that they see.
You can think that
they see pixels.
And they watch the pixels.
And the pixels are transforming.
And they look at the world
as things change around them
and so on.
And what this short clip is
trying to make explicit is,
somehow, these pixels,
over time, acquire meaning.
And they understand the
world, what they see.
The input changes from changing
pixels and light intensities
into other infants, and rooms,
and whatever they see around
them.
So we would like to be
able to understand this
and to do something similar.
So to have a system,
imagine that we
have some kind of a
system that starts
without any specific world
knowledge wired into it.
It watches movies
for, say, six months.
And at the end of
the six months,
this system knows about the
world, about people, about
agents, about animals,
about objects,
about actions,
social interactions
between agents the
way that infants do
during the first year of life.
So the goal isn't-- for me
at least, it's not really--
the interest is not
necessarily to engineer,
the engineering part of it to
really build such a system,
but to think about and develop
schemes that will be able
to deal with it and
do something similar.
I think it's also-- maybe
I'll mention it at the end--
it's also a very
interesting direction
for artificial
intelligence to think
about not generating
final complete systems,
but generating baby
systems, if you want,
that have some interesting
and useful initial capacities.
But the rest is just,
they watch the world,
and they get intelligent
as time goes by.
I'm going to talk initially
about two particular things
that we've been
working on and we
selected because we thought
it particularly interesting.
And one has to do with
hands, and the other one
has to do with gaze.
And the reason that we selected
them is, I'll show in a minute,
visually, for computer vision,
being able to deal with hands
of people's in images and
dealing with direction of gaze
are a very difficult problem.
And a lot of work has been
done in computer vision dealing
with issues related
to hands and to gaze.
They're also very important
for cognition in general.
Again, I will discuss
it a bit more later.
But understanding
hands and what they
are doing, interacting
with objects,
manipulating objects,
action recognition--
so hands are a part of
understanding the full scheme,
the whole domain of actions.
And social interactions
between agents is a part of it.
Gaze is also very
important for understanding
intentions of
people, understanding
interactions between people.
So these are two basic--
very basic type of
objects or concepts
that you want to acquire
that are very difficult.
And the final
surprising thing is they
come very early in infant
vision, one of the first things
to be learned.
So you can see here, when
I say hands are important,
for example, for
action recognition,
I don't know if you can
tell what this person is
doing, for example.
Any guess?
Yeah, you say what?
What is he doing?
AUDIENCE: Talking on the phone.
SHIMON ULLMAN:
Talking on the phone.
And we cannot really
see the phone.
But it's more where the hand is
relative to the ear and so on.
And you know, we can see the
interactions between agents
and so on.
A lot depends on understanding
the body posture,
and in particular, the hands.
So they are certainly
very important for us.
I mentioned that they
are very difficult to be
able to automatically
be able to extract them
and localize them in the image.
And there are two
reasons for this.
One is that hands
are very flexible,
much more so than
most rigid objects we
encounter in the world.
So a hand does not have
a typical appearance.
It has so many
different appearances
that it's difficult
to handle all of them.
And the other reason is that
hands in images, although they
are important, very often,
there is very little information
in the image showing the hand.
Just because of resolution
size, partial occlusion,
we know where the hands are.
But we can see very
little of the hands.
We have the impression
here, when we look at this,
we know what this
person is doing, right?
He's holding a camera
and taking a picture.
But if you take the
image-- you know,
where the hand and
the camera are--
you know, this is the
camera, this is the hand,
and so on-- it's really
not much information.
But we can use it
very effectively,
and similarly in the other
images that you see here.
Children, or infants, do this
ability to deal with hands--
and later on, we'll
see, with gaze--
in a completely
unsupervised manner.
Nobody teaches them,
look, this is a hand.
Even it cannot be even
theoretically possible,
because this capacity
to deal with, say,
hands and gaze comes at
the age of three months,
way before language
starts to develop.
So all of this is
entirely unsupervised,
just watching things happening
in an unstructured way
and mastering these concepts.
And when you try to imitate
this in computer vision systems,
there are not too many
computer vision system,
learning system that can deal
well with unsupervised data.
And I can tell you
without going--
I don't want to elaborate on
the different schemes that
exist and so on.
But the kind of thing
that exists cannot--
nobody can help,
nobody can learn hands
in an unsupervised way.
It may be interesting
to know, just
anecdotally, when we actually
started to work with this,
deep networks were not
exactly what they are today.
If you go back in
the literature,
and we see when the term "deep
networks" and the initial work
on deep networks started by--
at least in the group
of Geoff Hinton.
Yann LeCun was doing
independent things separately.
But the goal was
to learn everything
in an unsupervised way.
They were labeled as, that's
the goal of the project,
to be able to build a machine.
And the machine, you will
not need supervision.
You just aim it at
the world, and it
will start to absorb
information from the world
and build a internal
representation in a completely
unsupervised way.
And they demonstrated
it on simple examples--
for example, on MNIST
on digits, that you
don't tell the system that
there are 10 digits and so on.
You just show it data, and
it builds a deep network
that automatically
divides the input
into 10 different classes.
And in interesting ways,
it also divides subclasses.
There is a closed 4, and an
open 4, and so on with something
very natural.
And it was an example of
dealing with multiple classes
in an unsupervised manner.
But when you try to do
something like hands, which we
tried, I mean, there is just--
it basically failed as
an unsupervised method.
And the problem
remained difficult.
Here is a quote for
Jitendra Malik, who is--
those of you who deal
with computer vision
would know the name.
He's sort of a leading
person in computer vision.
"They say that dealing with
body configuration in general,
and hands in
particular, is maybe
the most difficult recognition
problem in computer vision."
I think that's
probably going too far.
But still, you can realize
that people took it
as a very difficult problem.
On the unsupervised way, which
is still a big open problem,
the biggest effort so
far has been a paper--
it's already a few years ago--
a collaboration between
Google and Stanford
by Andrew Ng others in
which they took images
from 10 million YouTube movies.
And they tried to
learn whatever they
could in an unsupervised way.
And they designed a system that
was designed to get information
out in an unsupervised manner.
And basically, they managed,
from all this information,
to get out three concepts
what happened in the machine
that you-- it developed
units that were sensitive,
specifically, to three
different categories.
One was faces, the
other one was cats.
That's from their paper.
It's not easy to see the cat
here, but there is a cat.
They found the cat.
And there is a sort of a
torso, upper body from--
upper body.
Three concepts-- after all of
this training, three concepts
sort of emerged.
And in fact, only
one of them, faces,
was really there, that
there were units that
were very sensitive to faces.
For the other cases, like
cats and upper bodies,
it was not all that selective.
And by the way, cats
is not very surprising.
You know why cats came
out in these movies?
If you watched YouTube
you would know,
literally, it's also
the most salient thing.
After faces, it's
literally the case
that if you take random
movies, or millions
of movies from YouTube, many,
many of them will contain cats.
So in the database, it was the
most-- after faces and bodies,
it was the third most
frequent category.
So it wouldn't do,
hands or gaze and so on.
It's really picking
up only things
which are very, very
salient and very, very
frequent in the input.
And as I said, babies do it.
And now people started to work
to look more closely at it.
One technique was to put a
sort of webcam on infants.
This is not an infant.
This is a slightly
older person, a toddler.
But they do it with
infants, and they look
at what the babies are looking.
And what babies are looking
at the very initial stages
are faces and hands.
They really like faces.
And they really like hands.
And they recognize hands.
And they know sort of what--
they have, already, information
and expectation about hands
in a very early age.
So it's not just even the visual
recognition that they group
together images
of hands, but they
know that hands, for example,
are the causal agents that are
moving objects in the world.
And this is for an
experiment by Rebecca Saxe.
There is a person here working
with Rebecca Saxe, right?
Did she talk already in the--
AUDIENCE: She will.
SHIMON ULLMAN: She will.
And she's worth listening to.
So this is from
one of her studies
in which they showed infant--
these are slightly
older infants.
But they showed infants,
on the computer screen,
a hand moving an object.
This is not taken from
the paper directly.
This, I just drew-- but
a hand moving an object--
in this case, a cup or a glass.
And the infant watches it for
a while and sort of gets bored.
And after they do it,
they show the infant
either the hand moving alone on
the screen or the glass moving
alone on the screen.
And the hand moving alone,
on itself, on the screen,
they are not--
still bored.
They don't look at it much.
When the cup is
moving on the screen,
they are very surprised
and interested.
So they know it's the
hand moving the cup.
It's not the cup moving the
hand or they have equal status,
it's the motion of
this configuration.
The originator, or the actor,
or the mover is the hand.
So this is at seven months.
But it has been known that this
kind of motion that this one--
that an object can cause
another object to move,
this is something that babies
are sensitive to, not only
at the age of seven
months, but it's
something that appears in
infants as early as you
can imagine.
And you can test.
And this, for us--
I'll tell you what
they are sensitive to.
And for us, this was sort of the
guideline, or sort of the door,
the open door, how to--
what may be going on that
lets the infant speak up
specifically on hands
and quickly develop
a well-developed face detect--
hand detector.
So infants are
known to-- have been
known to be sensitive-- they are
sensitive to motion in general.
They are really
following moving objects.
And they use motion a lot.
But motion by itself
is not very helpful
if you want to recognize hands.
It's true that hands are moving.
But many other things
are moving as well.
So if you take random videos
from children's perspective,
they see doors
opening and closing.
They see people
moving back and forth,
coming by and disappearing.
Hands are just one small
category of moving things.
But they're also sensitive,
as I said, not just to motion
but to this particular situation
in which an object moves,
comes in contact with another
object, and causes it to move.
And this is not even at
the level of objects.
At three months, they don't
even have a well-set notion of--
they just begin to organize the
world into separate objects.
But you can think of
just cloud of pixels
if you want, moving around.
They come in contact
with stationary pixels
and causing them to move.
Whenever this happens,
infants pay attention to this.
They look at it preferentially.
And it's known that they
are sensitive to this type
of motion, which
called a mover event.
And a mover event is
this event that I just
described that
something is in motion,
comes in contact with
a stationary item,
and causes it to move.
So we started with developing
a very simple algorithm
that, all it does, it
simply looks on video,
on changing images,
watching for, or waiting
for, mover events to occur.
And the way it's defined,
it's very simple.
In the algorithm, we
divide the visual field
into small regions.
And we monitor each
one of these cells
in the grid for the
occurrence of a mover, which
means that there will be some
optical flow, some motion
coming into the cell, and
then leaving the cell,
and sort of carrying with
it the content of the cell.
So this does require
some kind of optical flow
in change detection.
And all of these
capacities are known
that they're in place
before three months of age.
And now, look at an image of
a person manipulating objects
when all you do
is simply monitor
all locations in the
image for the occurrence
of this kind of a mover event.
What you should see, or what
you should pay attention to,
is the fact that
motion, by itself,
is not particularly--
is not doing anything.
What the algorithm
is doing is, whenever
it detects a mover
event, it draws a square
around the mover
event and continues
to follow it to track
it for a little bit.
So you can see, the minute
the hand is moving something,
it's detected as a hand
moving things on their own,
are not triggering
the system here.
The hand is moving.
So this, by itself,
is not the signal.
But the interaction between
the hand and an object
is something that
it's detected based
on these very low-level cues.
It doesn't know about hands.
It doesn't know about objects.
But you can create-- you can
see, here, a false alarm, which
was interesting.
You can probably
understand why, and so on.
So here's an example of
what if you just let it--
this scheme run on a large set
of hours and hours of videos.
Some of these videos
do not contain anything
related to people.
Some of them, there are people,
but just going back and forth,
entering the room,
leaving the room,
but do not manipulate objects.
Nothing specific
happens in these videos.
The system that is looking for
these kinds of mover events
finds very rare
occasions in which
anything interesting happens.
But you can see the
output that happened.
This is just examples
of output of just,
from these many videos,
the kind of images
that it extracted by being tuned
specifically to the occurrence
of this specific event.
You can see that you
get a lot of hand.
These hands are
the continuation.
The assumption here, which
we, again, took and modeled
after what--
when infancy, something
that starts to move,
they track it for about
one or two seconds.
So we also tracked it for
about one or two seconds.
And we show some images
from this tracking.
These are some false alarms.
There are not very many of them.
But these are examples
of some false alarms,
that something happened
in the image that
caused the scheme for
the specific mover event
to be triggered.
And it collected these images.
But on the whole,
as it shows here,
you get very good performance.
It's actually surprising that,
if you look at all the ima--
all the occurrences of
hands touching objects,
that 90% of them in all
these collection of videos
were captured by the image.
And the accuracy was 65%.
So there were some false alarms,
but the majority were fine.
And what you will end up with
is a large collection which
is mostly composed of hands.
So now you have,
without being supplied
with external supervision--
here is a hand, here is a hand,
here is a hand--
suddenly, you have
a collection of 10,000 images.
And most of them contain a hand.
And now if you look at this,
and you apply completely
standard algorithms
for object recognition,
this is great for them--
this is sufficient for them--
in order to learn a new object.
So if you do a deep network--
but you can do even simpler
algorithms of various sorts--
what you will end up using this
collection of images, which
were identified as belonging
to the same concept
by all triggering the same
special event of something
causing something to move,
you will get a hand example.
So these are just--
I will not play them--
lots and lots of movies.
Some of them can play
with for half an hour
without having a single
event of this kind.
Others are pretty
dense with such events.
And they are being detected.
And what is shown here,
it's not the greatest image.
But all these squares here,
the yellow squares, are--
having gone through this first
round of learning these events,
this is the output
of a detector.
You take the images that
were labeled in this way.
You give it to a standard
computer vision classifier
that takes these
images and finds what's
common to these images.
And then on completely new
images-- static images now--
this marks, in the
image, following
this learning, where the
hands will be-- the hands are.
Now, this is a very
good start in terms
of being able to learn hands,
and not only learn hands.
As I showed you before, very
early on, the notion of learn
is automatically a sort of--
in terms of the
cognitive system,
is closely associated with
moving objects, causing objects
to move, as we saw in the
Rebecca Saxe experiment.
This also happens
in this system.
But this continues to develop.
Because eventually we can
learn hands not only in
this grasping configuration.
Later on we want to
be able to recognize
any hand in any configuration.
And so the system
needs to learn more.
And this is accomplished
by something
that, again, the details, or
the specific application here,
is less important
than the principle.
And the principle is
sort of two subsystems
in the cognitive system
training each other.
And together, by each
one advising the other,
they reach, together,
much more than what
any one of the systems would
be able to reach on its own.
And the two subsystems
in this case, one
is the ability to recognize
hands by their appearance.
I can show you just an image of
a hand without the rest of it,
the rest of the body or
the rest of the image.
And you know, by the
local appearance,
that this is a hand.
You also know, here, you cannot
even see the hands of this
woman.
But you know where
the hands are.
So you can also use the
surrounding context in order
to get where the hands are.
So these are two
different algorithms that
are known in computer vision.
They are also known in infants.
People have demonstrated, sort
of independently before we
have done our work, that infants
associate the body, and even
the face--
when they see a hand,
they immediately look up,
and they look for a face.
And they are surprised if
there is no face there.
So they know about the
association between body parts
surrounding the hand
and the hand itself.
And you can think about it as--
we saw this image before.
Here the hand itself
is not very clear.
But you can get to the hand by--
if you know where the face is,
for example, that you
can go to the shoulder,
and to the upper arm, and lower
arm, and end up at the hand.
So people have used
this in computer vision
as well, finding hands.
They also use this idea of
finding the hands on their own
by their own appearance or
using the surrounding body
configuration.
And the nice thing is,
instead of just thinking of,
here are two
methods, two schemes
that can both produce the same
final goal, they can also,
during learning, help each
other and guide each other.
If you think about
it, the way it
goes it is shown here, that,
sort of, the appearance can
help finding hands
by the body pose.
And the body pose can
do the appearance.
So if you think, for
example, that, initially,
I learned this particular hand
in this particular appearance
and pose, then I learn
it by appearance.
I learn it by the pose.
But then if, for example,
I keep the same pose
but change completely the
appearance of the hand,
I still have the pose guiding
me to the right location.
And then I grab a new image
and say, OK, this is still
a hand, but a new appearance.
Now that I have
the new appearance,
I can move the new
appearance to a new location.
So now I can recognize
the hand by the appearance
that I already know.
But then, this is a
new pose, so I say aha.
So this is still a
new body configuration
that ends in a hand.
And then I can change
the appearance again.
So you can see that by
having enough images,
I can use the
appearance to learn
various poses that
end up in a hand using
the common appearance
and vice versa.
If I know the pose, I
can use the same pose
and deduce from the different
appearances of the same hand.
And this becomes--
I will not go into
the algorithms,
but this becomes very powerful.
And just by going through this
iteration in which you start
from a small subset of
correct identification,
but then you let these two
schemes guide each other--
this kind of learning that
one system guides the other--
we see, here, graphs
of performance.
Roughly speaking, the details
are not that important.
This is called a
precision recall graph.
But even without
explaining the details
of recall and precision,
the higher graphs
mean better performance
of the system.
And this is the
initial performance
of what you get if you
just train it using hands
grabbing objects.
Actually, the accuracy of
the system-- the system
is doing a good job
at recognizing hands,
but only in a limited domain
of hands touching objects.
So other things, it does
not recognize very well.
So this is shown here,
that it has high accuracy,
but does not cover all the
range of all possible hands
that you can learn.
And then without
doing anything else,
we just continue
to watch movies.
But you also integrate
these two systems.
Each one is supplying internal
supervision to the other one.
Everything grows, grows, grows.
And after a while,
after training
with several hours of video,
we get up to the green curve.
And the red curve is sort of the
absolute maximum you can get.
This is using the best
classifier we can get.
And everything is
completely supervised.
So on every frame, in
10,000 frames or more,
you tell the system where
exactly the hand is.
So this is what you can get with
a completely supervised scheme.
And this, the green,
is what you can
get with reasonable training--
I mean, seven hours of training.
Infants get more training--
completely unsupervised.
It just happens on its own.
It's interesting,
also, to think about--
if you think about infants--
and actually, I wanted to--
I was planning to ask you
the question here let's see.
What else could
help infants do--
if you can think of other
tricks in which infants somehow
have to pick up, it's
very important for them
to pick up hands.
What other signals, or
tricks, or guidelines
could help them pick up hands?
And OK, since I sort
of gave up own hands,
you can think about babies
sort of waving their hands.
And babies do wave their
hands a lot in the air.
And you can think of a scheme
in which the brain knows this.
And you sort of wave hands.
And then the images that are
generated by these motive
activities interpreted
by the system,
it already knows, grab this,
and somehow, use them in order
to build hand detectors.
There is evidence that this
is, I think, interesting.
And we know that infants are
interested in their own hands.
But there are reasons to believe
that this is not the case.
Because for example,
if you really try this,
and you try to learn hands from
waving your hands in this way,
imitating what infants
may see, a scheme
that learns hands in this way
is very bad at recognizing hands
manipulating objects.
If, after waving the
hands, you test the system,
and there is a hand
coming in the image
and touching,
grabbing something,
the difference in
appearance in point
of view between
waving your own hands
and watching somebody
grabbing an object
is so large that it does
not allow to generalize well
at this stage.
And we know, from
testing infants,
that the first thing
that they recognize well
is actually other
hands grabbing objects.
So it's much more
consistent with the idea
that the guiding
internal signal that
helps them deal, in
an unsupervised way,
with this difficult task is
the special event of the hand
as the mover of objects.
OK, I want to move
from hands to--
this will be shorter, but I want
to say something about gaze.
Gaze is also, as I
said, interesting.
It starts at about
three months of age.
An infant has this capability.
What happens at three months of
age is that an infant may look
at an adult-- at a
caregiver, the mother, say,
or look at another person--
and if the other
person is looking
at an object over
there, then the infant
will look at the other person,
and then will follow the gaze,
and will look at the object that
the other person is looking at.
So it's, first of all,
the identification
of the correct
direction of gaze,
but also then using it in
order to get joint attention.
And all of these
things are known
to be very important in
early visual development.
And psychologists,
child psychologists,
talk a lot about this
mechanism of joint attention
in which the parent, or the
caregiver, and the child
can get joint attention.
And some people,
some infants, do not
have this mechanism
of joint attention,
being able to attend
to the same event
or object that the other
person is attending to.
And this has developmental
consequences.
So it's an important aspect
of communication and learning.
So understanding direction
of gaze is very important.
And here it's even perhaps more
surprising and unexpected even
compared to hands.
Because gaze, in some
sense, doesn't really
exist objectively out
there in the scene.
It's not an object, a
yellow object, that you see.
It's some kind of an
imaginary vector, if you want,
pointing in a particular
direction based
on the face features.
But it's very non-explicit.
And you have, somehow, to
observe it, and see it,
and start extracting
it from what you see,
and all of this in a
completely unsupervised manner.
So what would it
take for a system
to be able to watch
things, get no supervision,
and after a while, extract
correctly direction of gaze?
Direction of gaze
is actually depend
on two types of
sources of information,
one of the direction
of the head,
and the other is the direction
of the eyes in the orbit.
And both of them are important.
And you have to master both.
There are more recent
studies of this,
and more accurate
but I like this reference.
Because this is from
a scientific paper
on the relative effect of hand--
of head orientation and eyes'
orientation in gaze perception.
And it's a scientific
paper in 1824.
So this problem was
studied with experiments,
and the good
judgment, and so on.
The point here, by the
way, is that these people
look as if they are looking
at different directions.
But in fact, the eyes
here are exactly the same.
It's sort of cut and paste.
It's literally the
same eye region,
and only the head is turning.
And this is enough to cause
us to perceive these two
people as looking in two
different directions.
In terms of inference and how
this learning comes about,
the head comes about first.
And initially, if the
caregiver, as I said, is--
the head is pointing in
a particular direction
but the eyes are
not, the infants
will follow the head direction.
Later on-- so this
is at three months.
Later on, they combine the
information from the head
and from the eyes.
And the eyes are
really subtle cues
which we use very
intuitively, very naturally.
But although it's-- let
me hide this for a minute.
This person-- it's a bad image.
It's blurred, especially
those who sit in the back.
But this person, is he looking,
basically, roughly at you,
or is he looking at
the objects down there?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: audience
SHIMON ULLMAN: Yeah,
basically at you, right?
Now, if you look at the--
so it's from the eyes.
And this is the--
these are the eyes.
This is all the information.
This is the right pixels, the
same number of pixels that
are in the image, and so on.
So this is the
information in the eyes.
It's not a lot.
And we use it
effectively in order
to decide where the person
is-- we just look at it.
And it's interesting that it's
so small and inconspicuous
in some objective terms.
But for us, we know that the
person is looking, roughly,
at us.
Now, we have some computer
algorithms that do gaze.
And gaze, again, it's
not an easy problem.
And people have
worked quite a lot
on detection, detecting
direction of gaze.
And all the schemes
are highly supervised.
And once it's highly
supervised, you can do it.
So by highly supervised, I
mean that you give the system
many, many images in
which you give the image,
but you also give
the learning system--
together with the input
image, you supply it
with the direction of gaze.
So this is the image,
and this is the direction
the person is looking at.
And there are ways of getting
this input information
of the appearance of the face
and the direction of gaze,
to associate them, and then when
you see a new face, to recover
the direction of gaze.
But it really depends on a
large set of supervised images.
So we need something to-- if
you want to go along the same
direction that happened before
with getting hands correctly,
we want-- instead of the
internal supervision, we want--
some kind of a signal that
somehow can tell the baby,
can tell the system--
without any explicit
supervision,
provide some kind of
an internal teaching
signal that will tell it where
is the direction of gaze.
It's very close to
the hand and the mover
using the following
notion, that if I pick up
an object, which was very
close to the mover event,
once I picked up an object, I
can do whatever I want with it.
I don't have to look at it.
I can manipulate it and so on.
But if it's placed somewhere
and I want to pick it up,
nobody picks up
objects like this.
I mean, when you
look at objects,
when you pick them up, at the
moment of making the contact
to pick them up,
you look at them.
And in fact, that's a
spontaneous behavior which
we checked psycho-physically.
You just tell
people, pick objects.
You don't tell them what
you are trying to do.
And they're invariably
always-- at the instant
of grabbing the object, making
the contact, they look at it.
So if we have, already,
a mover detector,
or sort of a hand detector,
or a mover detector,
that hands that are
touching objects and causing
them to move, all
you have to do--
whenever you take
an event like this,
it's not only useful for hands.
But once a hand is touching
the object, this kind of mover
event, you can freeze your
video, you can take the frame.
And you can know
with high precision
that you can-- now
the direction of gaze
is directed toward the object.
So we asked people to manipulate
objects on the table and so on.
And what we did is we ran
our previous mover detector.
And let me skip the movie.
But whenever this kind of a
detection of a hand touching
an object, making initial
contact with an object
happened, we froze the image.
Unfortunately, this is
not a very good slide,
so it may be difficult to see.
Maybe you can see here.
So we simply drew
a vector pointing
from the face in the direction
of the detected grabbing event.
And we assumed-- we don't know--
that's an implicit, internal,
imaginary supervision.
Nobody checked it.
But we grabbed the image,
and we drew the vector
to the contact point.
So now you have a system--
on the one hand,
we have face images
at the point where
we took the contacts.
So here is a face.
And this is a
descriptor, some way
of describing the
appearance of the face based
on local gradients.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: How do
you find the face?
SHIMON ULLMAN:
You assume a face.
The face detector, I just left--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SHIMON ULLMAN: Right.
Right.
Faces come even before--
I didn't talk about faces, but
faces come even beforehand.
As I mentioned, the first thing
that infants look at is faces.
And this is even
before the three months
that they look at hands.
This is to-- the current
theory is that faces,
you're born with a primitive
initial face template.
There are some discussions
where the face template is.
There is some evidence that
it may not be in the cortex.
It may be in the amygdala.
But there is some
evidence for this face.
For manipulation of these
patterns that infants look at,
it's a very simple
template, basically
the two eyes, or something
round, with two dark blobs.
And this makes them fixate more
on faces in a very similar way
to the handling the hands.
You just-- if you do
this, from time to time,
you will end up
focusing not on a face,
but on some random
texture that has
these two blobs or something.
But if you really
run it, then you
will get lots and
lots of face images.
And then you'll develop a
more refined face detector.
So babies, from day one by the
way, the way we think that--
the way people think it's innate
is you can work-- it is done--
experiments have been done
with the first day when
babies were born, the day one.
They keep their eyes
closed most of the time.
But when they are
open, they fixate.
You have to make big
stimuli, because it's
like close-up faces, because
the acuity is still not
fully developed.
But you can test what
they're fixating on.
And they fixate
specifically on faces.
And once there is a
face, they fixate on it.
And the face can move, and
they will even track it.
So this is day one.
So face seems to be innate
in a stronger sense.
In the case of the hand,
for example, as I said,
you cannot even imagine
building a innate hand detector
because of all this
variability in appearance.
For the face, it seems that
there is an initial face
detector which gets elaborated.
So we assume that there is
some kind of-- in these images,
we assume that when we grab
an event of contact like this,
the face is known, the location
of the face, the location
of the contact is known.
And you can draw a vector
from the first to the second.
And this is the
direction of gaze.
And when, now, you see a
new image in which there
is no contact, you
just have the face,
and you have to decide what
is the direction of gaze,
you look at similar faces that
you have stored in your memory.
And from this stored
face in memory, for this,
you already know from
the learning phase
what is associated
direction of gaze.
And you retrieve it.
And this is the kind
of things that you do.
What we see here with
the yellow arrows
are collected
images, which, again,
the direction of gaze,
the supervised direction,
has been collected, or was
collected, automatically,
by just identifying the
direction to the contact point.
These are some examples.
And what this shows is just
doing some psychophysics
and comparing what
this algorithm-- which
is sort of this infant-related
algorithm which just has
no supervision, looking
images for hands touching
things, collecting
direction of gaze,
developing a gaze detector.
So the red and the green, one
is the model, the other one
is human judgment on
a similar situation.
And you get good agreement.
I mean, it's not perfect.
It's not the state
of the art, but it's
close to state of the art.
And this is just training
with some videos.
I mean, this certainly does
at least as well as infants.
And it keeps developing,
getting from here
to a better and better gaze
detector with reduced error.
Well, the error is
pretty small here too.
But you can improve it.
That's already-- that's more of
standard additional training.
But making the
first jump of being
able to deal with
this nonexistent gaze,
collecting a lot of data
without any supervision, which
is quite accurate, about
where the gaze is and so on,
this is supplied by, again,
this internal teaching signal
that can come instead of
any external supervision
and make it unnecessary.
And you can do it without
the outside supervision.
It also has, I think, some--
the beginning of the more
cognitive correct association,
like the hand is
associated with moving
object, direction of gaze
and going to where the--
following it to see what is
the object at the other end
and so on, this is--
gaze is associated
with attention
of people, what they are
interested in at the moment.
So it's not just
the fact that you
connect the face with the
target object and so on.
It's a good way of creating
internal supervision.
But it also starts to, I think,
create the right association
that hand is associated
with manipulation and goals
of manipulating objects.
And gaze is associated
with attention,
and what we are paying
attention to, and so on.
So you can see that
you start to have--
based on this, if you
have an image like this,
and you can detect hands,
and you know, what--
there's a scheme that does it.
You know about hands.
You know about
direction of gaze.
You know about-- I
didn't talk about it,
but you also follow which
objects move around.
And you know which
objects are movable
and which objects
are not movable--
so a very simple scheme
that follows the chains
of processing that I described.
So it already starts to know--
you know, it's not quite
having this full representation
in itself.
But it's thought quite along the
way that the two agents here.
The two agents are
manipulating objects.
And the one of the
left is actually
interested in the object that
the other one is holding.
So you have all
this, the building
blocks to start build--
to start having an
internal description
along this line following
the chain of processing
that I mentioned.
And by the way, this
internal training
that one thing can train
another, if you want,
simple mover can train the hand.
Mover and a hand together
can train a gaze detector.
It turns out that gaze is
important in learning language,
in disambiguating
nouns and verbs
when you learn
language, when you
acquire your first language.
So this is from verb learning
for a particular experiment.
But let me ignore that.
A simple example would be
acquiring a noun that I say.
I say, suddenly, oh,
look at my new blicket.
And people have done
experiments like this.
And I can say,
look at my blicket,
looking at an object
on the right side
or looking at another
object on the left side,
saying exactly the
same expression.
And people have shown
that infants exposed
to this kind of situation,
they automatically
associate the term,
the noun "blicket,"
with the object that
has been attended to.
Namely, the gaze
was used in order
to disambiguate the reference.
So you can see a nice--
starting with very low-level
internal guiding signals
of, say, moving pixels that
can tell you about hands
and about direction of gaze--
and then direction of gaze
helps you to disambiguate
the reference of words--
so these kinds of trajectories
of internal supervision
that can help you learn
to deal with the work.
This is, to me, a part of a
larger project, which we called
the digital baby, in which we--
it's an extension of this.
We really want to
understand, what
are all these various
innate capacities that we
are born with cognitively?
And we mention, here, a number
of suggested ones-- the mover,
how the mover can train a gaze,
and the core training of two
systems.
And some of the things we think
that are happening innately
before we begin to learn.
And then we would like
to be able to watch
lots and lots of sensory
input, which could be visual.
It can be, in
general, non-visual.
And from this, to
generate, what will
happen is the automatic
generation and lots
of understanding of the
world, concepts like hands
and intention, direction
of looking, and eventually,
nouns, and verbs, and so on--
so how we'll be able to do it.
Know that it's very different
from the less structured
direction of deep networks,
which are interesting and are
doing wonderful things.
I think that they're
a very useful tool.
But I think that they are not
the answer to the digital baby.
They do not have the capacity
to learn interesting concepts
in an unsupervised way.
They do not distinguish.
They go, as I showed you
at the very beginning,
with the cats, and the
upper body, and so on.
They go only for
the salient things.
Gaze is not a salient thing.
I mean, we have
internal signals that
allow us to zoom in
on meaningful things.
Even if they are
not very salient
objectively in the
statistical sense,
there is something inside
us that is tuned to it.
We are born with it.
And it guides us
towards extracting
this meaningful
information, even
if it's not all that salient.
So all of these
things are missing
from the unstructured
net-- or the networks which
do not have all of this
pre-concept and internal
guidance.
And I don't think that they
could provide a good model
for cognitive learning in this
sense of the digital baby.
Although I can see a very useful
role for them, for example,
as just--
in answer to Doreen's question,
that if you want to then get--
from all the data and
the internal supervision
that you provided, you want to
get an accurate gaze detector,
then training, using
supervision training
in appropriate deep networks
can be a very good way to go.
I wanted to also show you,
this is not directly related,
but it's something impressive
about the use of hands in order
to understand the world, just to
show you how smart infants are.
I talked more about
detecting the hands.
It was more the
visual aspect of,
here is an image,
show me the hand.
But how they use
it-- and this is
at the age of about one
year-- maybe 13 months,
but one year of age.
Here's the experiment.
I think it's a really
nice experiment.
This experiment was
with a experimenter.
This is the
experimenter, one image.
What happened in
the experiment is
that there was a sort of a
lamp that you can turn the lamp
on by pressing it from above.
It sort of has this dome shape.
That's the whites in here.
You press it down,
and it turns on.
It shines blue light,
and it's very nice.
And babies like it.
And they smile at
it, and they jiggle,
and they like this turning
of the bright light.
And during the
experiment, what happens
is that the infant is
sitting on its parent's lap.
And the experimenter is on the
other side, that experimenter.
And she turns on the light.
But she turns on the light--
instead of pressing it,
as you'd expect,
with her hand, she's
pressing on it
with her forehead.
She leans forward,
and she presses
the lamp, this dome,
and the light comes on.
And then, these are babies that
can already manipulate objects.
So after they see it
three or four times,
and they are happy seeing
the light coming on,
they are handed
the lamp and asked
to turn it on on their own.
And here is the
clever manipulation.
For half the babies,
the experimenter
had her hands concealed.
She didn't have her
hands here, you see?
No hands are under this poncho.
Here it's the same,
very similar thing,
but the hands are visible.
Now, it turns out
that the babies--
or the in-- these are
not babies anymore.
These are young infants--
some of them, when they
were handed the lamp,
they did exactly what
the experimenter did.
They bent over, and pressed
the lamp with their forehead,
and turned it on.
And other children, instead
of-- although that's
what they saw, when they got
the lamp over to their side,
they turned it on by
pressing it with their hand,
unlike what they saw
the experimenter do.
Any prediction on your
side what happened--
you see these two situations--
when which babies--
I mean, in this case or in
this case, in which case
do you think they actually
did it with their hands
rather than using
their forehead?
Any guess?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: hands in
A and no hands in B
SHIMON ULLMAN: That's right.
And what's your reasoning?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SHIMON ULLMAN: But you
think about, you know,
baby, if you saw a baby, infant,
young one-year-old just moving
seemingly quasi-randomly and
so on, something like that
went on in their
head, that here, she
did it with her forehead.
She would have used
her hands, but she
couldn't, because
they were concealed,
and she couldn't use them.
So she used her forehead,
but that's not the right way
to do it.
I can do it
differently and so on.
That's sort of-- they
don't say it explicitly.
They don't have language.
But that's the kind of
reasoning that went on.
And indeed, a much larger
proportion-- so this
is the proportion of using their
hands where the green, I think,
was the hand occupied.
Or when the hands of the
experimenter is free,
you see that there is a big
difference between the two
groups.
So they notice the hands.
They ran through some kind
of inference and reasoning.
What hands are useful?
Why I should do?
Should I do it in the
same way because that's
what other people are doing?
Should I do it differently?
So I find it impressive.
So some general comment is--
general thoughts on learning
and the combination of learning
and innate
structures, that there
is a big sort of
argument in the field,
has been going on since
philosophers in ancient times,
whether human
cognition is learned.
This is nativism against
empiricism, where nativism
proposed that things
are basically--
we are born with what is
needed in order to deal
with the world.
And empiricism in
the extreme form
is that we are born with a blank
slate and just a big learning
machine, maybe like
a deep network.
And we learn everything from
the contingencies in the world.
So this is the empiricism
versus nativism.
In these examples, in an
interesting way, I think,
that complex concepts were
neither learned on their own
nor innate-- so for example,
we didn't have an innate hand
detector, but also,
it couldn't emerge
in a purely empiricist way.
But we had enough structure
inside that would not
be the final solution, but
would be the right guidance,
or the right infrastructure,
to make learning possible.
And this is not just a
very generic learner.
But in this case, the
learner was informed by--
you know, was looking for some
mover events or things like it.
So it's not the hands,
it was the movers.
And this guides the system
without supervision,
not only making
supervision unnecessary,
but also focusing the learner on
meaningful representations, not
necessarily just things which
are the first things that
jump at you statistically
from the visual input.
So there are these kinds
of learning trajectories
like the mover, hand, gaze, and
reference in language, of sort
of natural trajectories in
which one thing leads to another
and help us acquire
things which would be very
difficult to extract otherwise.
As I mentioned at
the beginning, I
think that there are some
interesting possibilities
for AI, as I said, to build
intelligent machines by not
thinking about the final
intelligence system,
but thinking about baby
system with the right internal
capacities which will make
it able to then learn.
So the use of
learning is sort of--
we all follow it.
But the point is, probably just
a big learning machine is not
enough.
It's really the
combination of, we
have to understand the
kind of internal structures
that allow babies to
efficiently extract information
from the world.
If we manage to put something
like this into a baby system
and let it interact
with the world,
then we have a
much higher chance
of starting to develop
really intelligent systems.
It's interesting,
by the way, that
in the regional paper by Turing,
when he discusses the Turing
test and how to build--
can machines think,
he discusses the issue
about building
intelligent machines
somewhere in the future.
And he says that his hunch
is that the really good way
of building, eventually,
intelligent computers,
intelligent machines
would be to build a baby
computer, a digital
baby, and let
it learn rather than
thinking about the final one.